this is one of the coolest clutches in
CS history so this is 2019 ESL cologne
in groups Vitality vers fanatic so if
Vitality lose this round it's it's it's
bad so you'll see in a second here this
is literally worst case scenario for
Vitality this is about to turn into a
1v4 for the boy zyu I'm going to walk
you through what he does okay swings out
head shot gets the instant trade on
twist that's the freebie right cuz zyu
could have been anywhere so that's the
one where it's like okay they didn't
know where he was boom so Z knows that
brol in his bank is the death cam he H's
into the back corner here he hard
commits this angle clears with the USP
here's the swing coming from Dice gets
the kill goes back into bank to get the
kit he's going to do the standard right
click smoke over dice to mass the
shot it is very rare that when someone
wins a 1v4 it's not because the other
team didn't throw in this case fanatic
honestly did nothing wrong I'm telling
you man this play one of my favorites